when we looked at our book we wrote it
with something in mind which was to defy
what the great philosopher Hegel said
which is he said that if there's one
thing history teaches us is that history
doesn't teach us anything people don't
learn from history so we decided we try
and learn from history from China a
hundred years before the Common Era but
then when we finished the book we said
well there is actually something about
the future and we'd like to think about
three trends that are really important
for corporations to think through and in
particular how their relationship with
society is going to work and they were
first the ever increasing possibility
that artificial intelligence will change
the way in which labor works how do we
communicate with companies what actually
do they do can they do things more
perfectly or will they become less human
we started the discussion by speaking to
Tim berners-lee and Tim rather
surprisingly said to me well John
the thing about artificial intelligence
is that corporations are already robots
they're already robots so there's
nothing new here they behave robotically
and maybe they shouldn't so I said well
I contend that they absolutely shouldn't
because they are part of the human
fabric of society so that was the first
thing we talked about the second we
worried about was the change in the
economic center of gravity in the world
if you go back to the first year after
in the Common Era
one ad you'd find that the center of
economic gravity in the world was
somewhere in the Middle East and over
the last a couple of thousand years it's
moved from there to the middle of the
Atlantic and now it's moving back to
somewhere in the East so it moves as
countries become
more comparatively advantaged more
educated and things move and therefore
values the way in which companies work
move again and we wanted to make the
point that our book is not about pure
moral values it's about practical
attempts to include people into this
great endeavor which is business which
makes the world better because actually
makes people more prosperous brings
people out of poverty and so forth so we
we wanted to do that and the third thing
we said was the business actually
doesn't have a right to be in the world
but it has to solve some of the very big
problems that are facing the world
obesity and the ingestion of too much
sugar climate change
diseases that chronic diseases that
exist water shortage pollution the list
goes on and we gave a dozen examples of
where we thought that in order to have
the right to be a company companies
should be focused on at least in some
part of their brain solving some of
these problems for the future and it
just may be that artificial intelligence
the ability to think more broadly to
gain access to more data to understand
more about it might just lead us to a
better solution to some of these
extraordinary problems that have been
around a long time it's just that we now
see them with greater clarity and indeed
they are being becoming more and more
dangerous climate change being a prime
example of something becoming more
dangerous